hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown how will the
nation emerge from protests and a
pandemic senator martha mcsalley says
america has a broken spirit the Arizona
lawmaker joins host Dave Anthony to
weigh in on what the country's leaders
must do to restore peace and help
Americans feel safe and secure again
also will civil unrest disrupt the US
economy's coronavirus recovery Neil
Cavuto anchor of your world on the Fox
News Channel and coast to coast on Fox
Business joins host Lisa Brady to
discuss how protests could affect the
economic bounce-back and businesses Plus
commentary by co-anchor of Fox and
Friends and the host of the Brian
Kilmeade show Brian Kilmeade the Fox
News rundown is a Daily News podcast
where we take a deeper look at the
stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to FoxNews podcast.com
Janis Dean I'm David Asman
I'm Dana Perino and this is the Fox News
rundown
[Music]
Wednesday June 3rd 2020 I'm Dave Anthony
protests have raged across America for
more than a week some peaceful some
destructive Republican senator martha
mcsalley tells us we're at a very
pivotal moment our spirit is is broken
and we've got to figure out how to move
past this and work together at all
levels leadership levels local levels
whatever it's going to take but violence
is not the answer i'm lisa brady
america's reopening gets interrupted how
much could civil unrest slow down the
pandemic recovery the irony will be that
you know the virus conditions haven't
proved enough to go back to work but
people are now of the opinion see maybe
I I shouldn't and I'm Brian Kilmeade
I've got the final word on the Fox News
rundown
the tension across America is even
thicker after two months of coronavirus
shutdowns more than a week of
destructive protests over George Floyd's
death in Minneapolis the country is
crying out for leadership presumed
Democratic presidential nominee Joe
Biden is this who we are is this what we
want to be is this we want to pass on to
our children and our grandchildren fear
anger finger-pointing but he pointed a
finger at President Trump he thinks
division helps him his narcissism has
become more important than the nation's
well being that he leads Biden is
calling for widespread police reform
I'll seek to heal the racial wounds that
have long plagued our country not use
them for political gain but that's just
what the Trump campaign claims Biden is
doing crassly using the unrest to
benefit his candidacy Republican Senator
John Cornyn told Fox she painted broadly
against all of our law enforcement
agencies across the country which i
think is grotesquely unfair another GOP
senator tells us we need calm as
thousands of National Guard troops help
police across the country I saw a convoy
of military vehicles go by and I had to
just do a double-take I did I've been
deployed six times it just was a scene
that I never thought I would see in
Washington DC
senator martha mcsalley from arizona is
also a retired Air Force colonel I
contrast it with the restaurants who
were scrambling in a frenzy to put up
wood over their glass out of fear for
the rioters and the looters right as
they were just getting ready and just
starting to open back up after the
pandemic these these hard-working
restaurant owners and poured their whole
lives into the restaurant on top of the
corner virus now they are scrambling
before the curfew to board up their
windows hoping and praying that that
their facility doesn't get destroyed in
the evening riots it's just this is
unbelievable that we are in this
situation and look everybody should
watch the video of the murder of George
George Floyd everybody is a human being
look away but what we're seeing happen
in our streets right now is those who
were more interested in anarchy and in
violence not in the memory of George
Floyd not in an honest serious
conversation about how we're going to
not look away from how that police
officer in broad daylight was able to
snuff that man's life out while others
stood around and enabled and watched him
but that's not what's going on right now
now we have destruction happening to
innocent people and it's got to stop and
it's time for us to unite this isn't
about you're a Republican or Democrat
we've got to work together we got to get
through this moment in our country it's
a pivotal moment we must get through it
together
now senator some have said that this is
something that they have to do that they
have to get people's attention that they
need to do this kind of thing with
destruction in addition to peaceful
protesting because peaceful protesting
doesn't always get the attention and
doesn't always work they need to make
change happen now there's nothing that
excuses violence there's just nothing I
hear their voice I share their discussed
about the callous despicable death of
George Floyd and the other examples in
the past I hear you I cannot begin to
relate to what it's like to be an
african-american man or woman in America
but I'm listening where we need to solve
this problem together but nothing
justifies violence nothing what would
you want done about policing in the wake
of what has happened would you want
Congress to get involved in any way you
know we're having conversations I'm open
to ideas but I we first have to address
the full justice for the murder of
George George Floyd I'm talking to local
leaders back in Arizona what more can be
done it's it's not a perfect analogy but
I was in the military I don't understand
how the Minneapolis Police Department
got to the place where that was allowed
to happen I don't understand leadership
matters Coulter matters you know
accountable
matters and and there's I got a lot of
questions as to what the hell was going
on in that's Police Department and
people need to be held accountable not
just a murderer but the facilitators and
and and others in the leadership who
created this environment it appears so
there's so much that needs to be looked
at not just there but in other places as
well but we've as a country we've got to
get through this together where we're at
a very pivotal moment our spirit is is
broken and we've got to figure out how
to move past this and work together at
all levels leadership level local levels
whatever it's going to take but violence
is not the answer
the president has wanted more governors
to call out the National Guard there
have been tens of thousands of troops
already deployed there are some
Democratic governors as they look
soldiers on the streets is not the
answer what do you think well in Arizona
we had a curfew we've had some rioting
and looting over the weekend and the
curfew started and there have been some
challenges but they've been able to
provide the very fundamental public
safety that's the responsibility of law
enforcement and if local law enforcement
can't do it on their own that's part of
the purpose of the National Guard and
for those who are the business owners
whose entire lives are being impacted to
those who are feel threatened because of
the the violence and the looting and the
rioting like bait the whole purpose of
law enforcement is to protect society
and so it's up to the individuals to not
be involved do not participate in this
violence and looting do not stand by and
watch it I am so proud of the people who
I've seen actually stand in the way you
see some of these protesters who were
just saying no don't do not we're here
to support George Floyd and to speak out
on these other issues please don't turn
this into you know a violent encounter
and they those people need to be held
accountable and local leaders need to
provide law order and safety on their
streets while we continue to have this
conversation about how to not have
something like George Floyd happen again
all this as senators still consider
whether to Peru
more spending to help people still
hurting from the coronavirus shutdowns
last month House Democrats approved a
three trillion dollar bill on top of the
nearly three trillion Congress passed
earlier but the Senate hasn't acted on
that whatever we need to do to get the
economy and Afterburner and defeat this
virus if we've got to do more
legislation let's focus on that and a
bipartisan way like we did in the past
this is not time to play politics it's
time to support small businesses support
workers who have been impacted
incentivising let's get back to being in
a strong economic situation like we were
while we're still having to defeat the
virus it's we can do both of them
together and I think Arizona has been a
model I've been out to restaurants I've
got my haircut I've got a pedicure
they're doing things differently but I'm
supporting those local businesses out
there and we can do that safely now
we've had about 40 million people file
for unemployment since the middle of
March do you think that maybe more money
needs to go out another stimulus checked
for everybody or extra on employment
I know people also worry that the
unemployment that has gone out is paying
some people more than they actually got
when they were working so what do you
think needs to be done there I've heard
stories of individuals not being willing
to come back to work that's actually not
allowed by labor law you can't quit your
job or refuse a job and get unemployment
I think Arizonans want to work I'll just
speak for my state we've got small
businesses that are needing to continue
to bring people back on the payroll
while they're able to safely open but at
lower capacity so whatever we need to do
that provide support so more people
don't fall into food and housing
insecurity while supporting those people
who are creating jobs for Arizonans and
Americans we've got to get people back
to work in a safe way get that economic
activity going in get that revenue
coming in martha mcsalley was appointed
to the Senate by Arizona's governor too
for the late Senator John McCain's seat
after she lost a 20-18 bid for the
state's other seat now there's a special
election this year and mcsally's
Democratic challenger is Mark Kelly who
said in a campaign video I learned a lot
from being an astronaut
a lot from being a pilot in the Navy I
learned a lot without solving problems
from being an engineer but what I
learned from my wife is how you use
policy to improve people's lives Kelly's
wife is for congresswoman gabrielle
Giffords who was shot in the head back
in 2011 but survived rehabbed and is now
a gun control advocate there are several
reports that polls have Kelly leading
senator mcsalley which is worrying the
Trump campaign the president tweeted
Tuesday that she is tough tested and
true calling her a fighter and he
recommended mcsally's new book which we
will get to in a moment well I you know
I think people are tired of politicians
of all they do is focus on their next
election that's one reason I went from
26 years in the military to yelling at
the television what's the matter with
those people who look at myself in the
mirror and saying well what are you
gonna do about it you know get in the
arena and do your part here we are at
this consequential place in our country
I think the best thing that I can do is
be a good senator and fight for
Arizonans make a difference for them yes
we have this very important fight coming
up I think most Americans understand
it's the most consequential election in
our lifetime and the best thing I can do
with only a two-year opportunity is to
be a good senator but I'm standing
between making sure that Senate majority
doesn't flip I'm standing on the wall to
make sure that we don't have structure
more Nancy Pelosi and Joe Biden in
charge and their extreme agenda on the
left I look at it like my dad died when
I was 12 if this is the last year of my
life what am i doing to make a
difference right now for Arizonans and
I'm honored to be able to serve them
right now and I'm gonna continue to
fight so I can continue to serve them in
the future
I know you wrote about your dad and and
your time in the military of nubuck
congratulations it's called dare to fly
simple lessons lessons and never giving
up it was just released late last month
you know I share my stories going from a
pudgy shy motion sick girl the last
night I was 12 to becoming the first
woman to fly a fighter jet in combat
commander fighter squadron in combat you
know all those stories have taken on the
Pentagon in an eight-year battle and you
know climbing Mount Kilimanjaro and
running our
and triathlons and other things and
those maybe unique stories but my
purpose of the book was to be a wingman
to the reader so I would probably
provide them practical ways that they
can overcome fear in their own lives
they can overcome their own adversity
and pain they can push past their own
barriers you mentioned you obviously the
first to fly female to fly a combat
mission how difficult was it to get to
that point in to reach that mark
difficult but you don't just go from you
know again being a shy motion sick kid
to just jumping into a fighter plane so
I share in very practical ways how
anybody can overcome their own fear
anybody can build courage I don't think
we're not born with courage and so the
day I was cleared for takeoff for
example in the a-10 it was a 10-year
journey to get there from when I went to
the Air Force Academy and said I want to
be a fighter pilot and it was against
the law and I was like you know we live
in America laws change 10 years later
I'm cleared for takeoff in the summer of
1994
no two sea planes no simulators I had
never flown it before and I share the
very practical stories of how I found my
courage in that moment and how I built
my courage over time like an athlete
building muscle memory and choices I
made in my life to allow me to not have
absence of fear but push up the power
and learn how to take off afraid and so
I share with the reader how you can do
things afraid in your own life and build
your own courage I think we could use a
little bit of that right now everybody
could well it's a lot of a lot of things
going on for all of us at this moment
and you especially working in the Senate
senator martha mcsalley thank you so
much for joining us this morning thanks
Dave you can go to dare to fly dot u.s.
get your book and also share your
stories with me god bless y'all stay
safe out there
[Music]
this is brian kilmeade with your fox
news commentary coming up
they went from shutdown to board it up
businesses trying to protect themselves
from looters we're a growing business we
just bought a bunch of new equipment had
it all literally stocked in here from a
couple weeks ago John limbs security
camera recording as thieves picked
through his ransacked TV business in
Santa Monica and just to watch it all
just getting yanked out was you know
it's it's devastating to watch
businesses of all sizes gutted or burned
windows shattered as peaceful protests
give way to violence
night after night when you loot a
business you're not just taking Goods
you're destroying someone's dreams
Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot and many
other officials condemning the damage
being done to minority-owned small
businesses in some cases even as the
family of George Floyd also calls for
peace the civil unrest sweeping a nation
just beginning to emerge from
coronavirus restrictions uncovered World
Bank
you know protests that happened in
places like Seattle in the past this is
a little different in that this seems to
grow on its own besides just the city
where leaders are meeting neil cavuto is
the host of your world on fox news
channel and coast to coast on fox
business did spread like wildfire
throughout the country and i think that
makes it very very different a lot of
people make the comparison you know to
1968 and racial and other riots that
that sort of took the nation by storm i
see those similarities but there is a
difference and then we're technically
not at war for the time being we're just
coming out of a virus that's gripped
much of the world so there are
differences but it is you know it's
obviously unnerving and i think the fact
that it this tends to have spawn
worldwide protests even in new zealand
in australia obviously throughout europe
latin america its hit a chord it's
definitely hit a chord that makes it
very very distinct do you have a sense
of how the recovery the economic
recovery from the pandemic was going
before the violent part of the protests
started the damage to businesses in some
areas it looked like people were
definitely ready to go shopping to eat
at restaurants for instance do we know
how that was going well what's going
fairly well and the rollout for say you
know states and cities
we're continuing their reopening was
pretty favorable there were you know
some spikes here and there but well
within the margin that a lot of the
medical experts thought and then this
happened I do find it interesting that
Wall Street has held its own that did
not continue to dancing on the belief
that this it will settle down that the
underlying economy is sound you know
I've heard those kind of arguments in
the past but it is unique in that it's
not rattling investors yet it's
certainly rattling average folks but
investors don't seem to think it will
amount to much more than these protests
the theory is that it escalates out of
control if the president makes good on
using the military to crack down
obviously that has shades of 1968 built
into it and fears that it just spirals
into this total bedlam but investors for
now I've been very you know what do you
say blase about it but actually they've
been a little bit dismissive of it
thinking that the worries that people
have that this leads to full-blown
Anarchy or just not I'm not there so I
guess in terms of how much it could
disrupt the recovery depends on how it
shakes out whether or not it does settle
down how that happens I think that you
know be careful what you you know
dismiss I think it's a little Cavalier
to say well this isn't going to affect
what I'm going to do but think about at
least well these the folks who were
planning eventually to go back either in
various phases
to their jobs knowing that New York City
is presently under this curfew would you
be eager to go back into the city
similarly in Chicago and Philadelphia in
the plant
Minneapolis obviously the center of all
of us it is going affect people's
judgement call as to whether it's safe
to go back so the irony will be that you
know the virus conditions have improved
enough to go back to work but people are
now with the opinion see maybe I I
shouldn't
it's interesting how maybe we would have
thought the big cultural change would be
more people working from home but now we
have an entirely different cultural
change that might be coming about in the
country in the not-too-distant future
because of everything that's happening
and I know Nordstrom for instance I just
wanted to ask you two about the the
different company responses to this
because that's something else that feels
different in this civil unrest compared
to the past Nordstrom sent out an email
to customers saying its heartbroken by
what it calls the senseless deaths and
they list George Floyd and others by
name and they say tremendous change is
needed to address the issues facing
black people in our country today now is
this indicative of a collective desire
for change or just a desire for the
looting to stop I know it's kind of a
cynical question but it's a question no
it really isn't which is a very good
question I always find that if
calamities like this I heard one analyst
tell me recently they get a conscience
sometimes too late but Bank of America
pledging 1 billion dollars to assist it
he can honor racial inequality and get
to the bottom of that you mentioned
Nordstrom you mentioned a host of others
that are exploring ways to understand
the communities in which they're in of
course it's your target and you've seen
more than two dozen of your stores you
know looted or damaged as a result of
protests I'm naturally going to put out
a statement that you're working with
those communities you know to get to the
bottom of the problem
said that target still has you know half
a dozen or more stores closed until
further notice to get to the bottom of
it
so they have to balance and explaining
to their public and their shareholders
how it is let's say in Amazon's case
Lisa they're there they're cutting and
limiting deliveries in some of the
cities that have been rocked by these
protests but at the same time putting
out statements we have to have a
dialogue exactly where they want to
understand those communities so they you
know they're trying to have it both ways
it's very very tough you're saying and
doing all the right things but obviously
if you're Bank of America you're an
Amazon or you're CBS and you're looking
at you know dozens of your stores closed
as a result of this you have to balance
business that's been clearly impacted by
this and and be very cognizant the fact
that you're drawing back on that
business but also with a sympathetic you
know ear to the complaints themselves
it's a very very tough position for
businesses some of the most heartwarming
images are of people helping just people
in their community helping businesses to
clean up regardless of what what type of
business just going out there
unsolicited and you know the morning
after you know the latest violence the
latest looting and just just trying to
help and working you know as a community
big difference between what happens in
the daytime and what happens at night in
a lot of the areas where these protests
are taking place I wanted to ask you
something on a positive note if it's
possible about businesses that have
actually been thriving during the
pandemic either because they're more in
demand because people were staying at
home or because they've reinvented
themselves one example would be that
company in Maryland that pivoted and
started making bumper tables and it
helped well they're doing but it's
sometimes these sort of desperate times
do breed innovation right
it is amazing to see now obviously some
are almost no brainers Amazon you can
see if people are sheltered at home
they'll shop at home and Amazon a big
beneficiary at that Walmart a very
strong online presence there beneficiate
out of course it's stores did then have
remained open throughout this I'll be it
with you know the checks on how many
people go into those stores but it's
those who make it as easy as possible
benefit I also find that a lot of the
the food delivery services that have a
product that's known unidentifiable
Domino's comes to mind that eat some
folks I mean those who make it easy and
are familiar brands did very well and I
imagine they'll do well post it one last
quick one because I know you have to run
but just second quarter how bad do you
think it'll be for the second quarter
GDP awesome it'll be just awful but but
it's well telegraphed that it's going to
be awfully so I think depending on how
people want to look at it we could see
the economy decline anywhere from thirty
to forty percent you know but it's all
factored in we already know kind of what
was going on and every week at every
month and we already know that the
numbers were record low numbers record
low retail sales record love personally
government spending numbers we're
grateful that they're just a little bit
better than awful awful that they're
just really awful but we already know
that now the question going forward is
do we bounce back from that the third
quarter seems to be the best shot of
doing that a lot of these numbers are
computed quarter-over-quarter
so the third quarter just based on the
lousy second quarter will exponentially
be a lot better we already know that as
well and then yet to the fourth quarter
we could be rounding to bend there are a
lot of people optimistic for 2021 saying
with you off to the races I'm not in the
camp that says it's going to be a
v-shaped recovery it well you go from
zero capacity to at least some capacity
and restaurant stores it isn't full
capacity so that takes time but it will
we're already prepared not only for
lousy employment numbers in a lousy GDP
for these months we're in and the second
quarter as a whole
that people are prepared for that what
they're what they're hoping for and what
guides the markets is the light at the
end of the tunnel and that is that it
gets better from here
fingers crossed Neil Cavuto last of your
post of your world on Fox News Channel
and coast-to-coast
on fox business thank you so much for
your time thank you Lisa very much
[Music]
[Music]
Network download and listen to everyone
talks to Liz Fox businesses liz claman
talks with entrepreneurs and executives
about inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to fox
news podcasts dot-com subscribe to this
podcast at fox news podcasts com it's
time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind we watch chaos in
major cities and everyone's focusing on
Donald Trump's walk to st. John's Church
or the fact that he was offered and may
give military support to these cities
that are out of control hey governors
hey mayor's don't worry about what
Donald Trump is saying don't worry about
where he's walking get your cities under
control get your state under control and
I'm talking to you Pritzker and I'm
talking to you Cuomo don't worry about
the walk don't worry about the military
your cities are full of chaos mayhem to
steal the New York Post term get it
under control and why is it that these
governors and mayor's seem to get a pass
because they're Democrats they're the
ones directly responsible for what's
going on Cuomo is a joke to have an 11
o'clock curfew why bother why not make
it 2:00 in the morning and have
mandatory eight hours sleep none of
which will ever happen or affect
anything else
there are infiltrators into your city
beyond protesters about racial inequity
and law enforcement policies there are
people coming in there to destroy the
country and they're doing if I destroy
the places you're in charge of so pull
it all together
there was a stat that said 70% of 77% of
white people trust the local police only
36% of black people do let's work on
that you want to make the country better
let's have a dialogue
policies that address that that have
blacks whites leaders everyday people as
well as guess who else law enforcement
involved in the conversation they don't
have to be bad guys we're all on the
same side we just want to make it better
but those rioters who are tearing apart
our cities are the bad guys stop
focusing on the President and bring some
semblance of normalcy to your state to
your city
I'm Brian Kilmeade and that's what I
think
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes